few months ago maybe even a few weeks
ago we got on sneako on the Channel with
young Don and Sheikh with Nico was
confronting us about Islam and a lot of
stereotypes if you guys haven't watched
that make sure you check that out but
fast forward to today present time this
is what he has to say and we want good
for him and we ask Allah to give us and
him
steadfastness upon the religion well
this gives me the chills man I'm not
going to Camp why I'm never gonna fully
say I'm a Muslim until um
I hate on drinking a done like bro that
is when are you gonna be done though
because I'm thinking about
um coming to Islam soon I think it
speaks to me more than Christianity yeah
I've been thinking that for a while this
guy tried to convert me not that long
ago we had a conversation up like that
and that the people I resonate with the
most um they they always seem to end up
in Islam and that's so respect to
Christianity or Judaism that's just what
speaks to me for the most part on seeing
this clip for the first time I was like
I was kind of worried bro after the
stream of sneak was like you know what I
don't know I don't know about Islam you
know but
no matter what you got to respect the
fact that some of the greatest minds of
our time and some of the most
the people that are speaking a lot of
Truth and amidst all this lies and
manipulation and deception they're
coming to Islam
some of the greatest minds of History
bro
so you gotta admit there's something
here even if you don't want to accept
Islam even if you don't want to look
into it you got to admit there's
something different about Islam than the
other religions they stand for something
they believe in something they're
willing to put their money where their
mouth is you can't buy their religion
you can't go to them and say I'll give
you a million dollars to denounce your
faith they're not gonna do it bro you
crazy someone could come to me with like
a billion dollar trillion bro
unimaginable
it's worth this what is it going to do
for me if we do get sneak on again
what do you want to ask him
it's a good question man
because I want to ask him like what are
you delaying for kind of start going
into what song You must talk about which
we'll react to the next video but you
don't need to make your life perfect to
become a Muslim do you want to go into
that what is Islam Islam is the belief
that there is no one worthy of worship
except Allah the one God the creator of
everything that exists he created you
and me so that we can worship Him and
Obey him right
that's what Islam is yes it's it's it's
more than that but when you boil it down
it's worthy basically one God worthy of
worship and the prophet Muhammad is his
last and final messenger the Quran is a
word of God the basic stuff all of that
yes it's Haram to drink but drinking
doesn't automatically mean you're not a
Muslim you could be a Muslim who commits
the sin of drinking and ask for
forgiveness and is forgiven by God now
that doesn't give anyone the right to to
drink with the intention of oh I'm gonna
ask for forgiveness and I'll be good
because obviously you're not sincere and
it's a safe person is not accepted by
Allah but if you sincerely believe in
Islam and believe in God and you submit
to him you will slip up once in a while
everybody does I do fire does it's just
a part of life but when you slip up you
ask for forgiveness you aim to aim to do
better that's it being a Muslim who
believes in Allah and prays and fast and
does his obligations but slips and
drinks and does whatever is better than
being a non-muslim because if you're a
Muslim then okay there's a chance you
will go to heaven if you're a good
person yeah you will go to heaven insha
Allah and even if you die in a state of
sin and you're punished eventually
you'll go to heaven because you're a
Muslim but if you are a non-muslim
especially if Islam came to you you
recognizes the truth and you don't
accept it you reject it then what place
is there for you except Hellfire Allah
has made it so clear for you and you
decided to turn away
and one of the tricks actually yeah go
on
no go Charlotte go ahead I'll save it I
was I was just gonna say one of the
tricks of shaitaan bro is to convince
people that we don't deserve Islam and
we can't be Hypocrites we can't be a
Muslim and sin although it is true bro
it is true let's not let's not cap it is
true if somebody is a non-muslim that's
never gotten Islam they never got the
message and they're sinning right
they're not going to be held to the same
standards a Muslim who got the message
and is we're not doubting that we're not
denying that but we're talking about the
people that are like they got the
message of Islam
and they choose to be in a state of
sinning without accepting Islam that's
not better than accepting Islam and then
sinning because at least if you accept
it you've you've done the most important
thing
which is what's in here yes you're
sinning I understand that what what son
of Adam is not a sinner bro but you've
accepted Islam which means you've
positioned yourself higher than a
non-muslim number two you can actually
repent now
and Allah would have destroyed
all of you know mankind if we didn't sin
so let's let's be honest now you know
I'm not single sin but let's repent
right repentant helps you know clean our
heart
and again at the end of the day bro at
least if you die you died a Muslim
not a disbeliever that's drinking
100 and you you would ask me earlier
if I could ask sneaker one question what
would it be um
my first thought was you know what's
holding you back
but I think a better question is is two
questions one
what is it that you worship
and he might say oh nothing I'm not
worshiping anything you are worshiping
something just like everyone else and
he'd mentioned that you know he has fun
doing whatever with with women and
drinking and going out in that stuff he
has fun doing that so you're worshiping
your physical desires
that's basically what you're worshiping
and another question is the question
that's us where are you going
where are you going
I know people don't like to hear it
but whoever is watching this you will
die yes you will die your soul will
leave your body you will be dead your
parents will look over your dead body
your family your children maybe will
even you know look over your dead body
in your casket and you will go under the
Earth and people forget about you you
will die I will die Allah says in the
Quran I've said it many times or said
this
on the podcast and I'll do it again
indeed you will die and indeed they will
die
and on the day of judgment you're all
going to dispute you're all going to
dispute no oh he did this and she did
that and all this stuff
so
where are you going you need to focus on
you know
you need to focus on the future you need
to focus on you know what is actually
the truth put everything else aside put
desires aside you know if Allah exists
and he created you
to worship Him
and you've been you know screwing around
for the last x amount of years just like
you know many other people were
then what is left except accepting Islam
turning to Allah obeying him and reaping
the rewards and the blessings that Allah
has for you come be a part of the Muslim
Community accept Islam be from those who
Allah loves
and you'll have the back and you'll have
the Muslim ummah at your At Your Service
to teach you about Islam and take you
under the wing and be there for you and
you've seen the power of the Muslims by
the way bro even if it's just online and
and kind of ganging up on you and saying
that's why I said you've seen the power
of the Muslims you've seen what Muslims
are willing to do out of love for for
Allah and the prophet in their religion
so imagine
once you also love Allah and the prophet
in their religion how much they will
love you Allah says in the Quran indeed
the Believers are but brothers so make
peace with your brothers
we are commanded in the Quran he said
you will basically you will not truly
believe it yeah you will not truly
believe until you love for your brother
what you love for yourself this is what
Muslims believe this is what Muslims
believe and if you want to be blessed in
this life and in the next you will
accept the truth of Islam and it's as
simple as that my genuine question to
you is where are you friends of your
views on Islam and your own personal
Journey with God
I like the respect that Islam promotes
and I think in the west I agree with
Tate I agree that like you the the
comparison is that you could walk around
uh with the shirt that says Jesus is gay
and nobody will blink an eye like I've
heard I've had one-on-one calls with
people and they said like yeah I'm going
to a party that's that's twerking for
Jesus and I'm like what gee that's and
Jesus like people being anti-christian
is marketed as
it's fun it's something it's it's like
the rappers are all like having a crop
dropping crosses and the and their album
covers it on screen they they use Satan
to promote their music it's
anti-christian in the west is a fun
thing that people use it's an aesthetic
choice but I like the fact that Islam
doesn't tolerate any of that and I I
think that most Islamic people have
their heads screwed on properly where
they have a sense of guidance that they
can follow that keeps their Morality In
check whereas a lot of other religions
and other
um
other
um thought what do you like trains of
thought it can it could derail you and I
think a lot of people now use their
political ideology as their religion
they use LGBT as their religion they use
like Democratic party and it's just like
that's not or they they adamantly
believe in
people and they worship celebrities and
politicians rather than God and I think
the best if you're going to follow
something it should be God
and in the west it hasn't been
Christianity and I personally grew up
Catholic
um just like Angel and Catholicism I
I've just seen a lot of hypocrisies in
it where like I we have something in in
Catholicism which is called confession
where you sit down and then you you
confess to the priests and you use and
then would it no matter what unit even
if you killed somebody like you can
literally confess a murder and be and
talk about getting out of wedlock any
sin and the priest will say all right
say ten Hail Mary's ten are fathers and
you're good and I sat in confession it
doesn't really sound like they're
listening I don't like it the fact that
they walk around with a donation basket
um I'm pretty sure it's the same with
with the mosque but
like the Christian Church doesn't pay
taxes a lot of people profit off of it
there's a lot of pastors like even on
YouTube some of the most highest um
super chatted channels on YouTube are
Christian pastors and I've just seen the
way that they flock to it it just seems
false and
it seems like they worship a lot of
false idols and people use Christianity
for the wrong things but Islam seems the
most grounded and it seems like it
promotes family values and conservative
values and
more than more than most people that
I've I've spoken with and especially the
people that I admire the most
um since I was a kid of all found is
even people that did not grow up with
Islam found Islam people that I admire
like Dave Chappelle Malcolm X and I
respect those people a lot and I I would
I like their trains of thought and I
think that that's a good thing to follow
that sounds good too
do you do you believe in one God
the truth is I want to more than I do I
think with my platform now and the way
things are going on in the west I think
it's important for me to promote
believing in God and I think it's a good
train of thought for people to follow us
but there's a lot of people that listen
to me and I think that believing in God
is the best is the best train of thought
to follow
but I to be perfectly honest I want to
believe in it more than I actually do
why is that what's what's stopping you